what's going on right here oh we got it
we talked about noodling last week
what's going on here Chappelle actually
heard after we posted our video with our
big shirtless friend that went popular
there's like a queen of noodling it's
Hannah barren she's just a star she had
some video of her pulling out of like a
40-pounder with her hand they got 15
million views and everybody was tagging
her in all our videos and I thought if
we wanted to learn a little bit more
about noodling we could try FaceTime her
I talked to her yesterday she was cool
with it and she was like just hit me up
she had a really busy day she was
waiting for Alec melt and she had to get
an AC for a boathouse
but she said trier she hasn't responded
today so she might not even answer all
right well let's chill out Tom Cruise of
noodling thank you find some five
minutes for King understand I think the
catfish can wait you feel me well shall
we try let's try er huh I think yeah I
think dicks sporting gonna let you give
you 10 minutes dude
you got to see one of our photos hurt
hey Hannah
miss noodle herself Hey hey Hannah can
you answer a Turner camera then she can
see both you can you turn your camera
sideways and you can see both of us yes
I'm going to my truck where I can hear a
little better oh hell yeah
hey man hey guys what's up work just a
couple of guys who are want to know more
about noodling yeah we want to know more
you're the queen queen ooodle
what's up Anna
we got the toys what happened what
happened oh well that's sweet who's
getting married it was supposed to be
yeah well are you getting them do people
like say if you have to get somebody a
gift for their wedding do they look at
you is like do they always think you're
gonna bring them in something from kind
of underwater put some fried catfish
bridesmaids oh wow that's a beautiful
bar I've got her some cooking stuff oh
nice that's a lot of responsibility now
so nobody reaches into the dark dark
abyss and pulls out something that you
could eat better than you what do you
think takes you to that next level as
far as noodle and goes like what is it
about you devil is it is it a body thing
is it a brain thing like you have lean
arms is it do you have kind of you know
do you kind of warmest type of fingers
Brendan as lean fingers yeah are you
just fearless is it a Fairless thing I
think it's more of a crazy thing than
fearless mm-hmm you gotta be a few
notches off in the head all right I like
that well I'd be pretty good at it
though yeah Brendan will just stay under
there for high redneck upbringing and my
dad's in the woods and on the water we
run shot lines coming up I've hunted
ever since I can walk I can clean a deer
by myself when I was 10 years old we
started it just got a bit and so now
you're good at catching these big dogs
underwater um
do
what is it does this transfer over into
your dating life like are you like how
is it for real and then these these land
cats these men surf-and-turf
yeah is it really
I'm sure yeah I'm sure your DMS are
filled with Noodlers yeah that's true no
I have a whole album and my phone is
dedicated to screen shots of weirdos
that either message me or comment on my
stuff I wish I could see that this is a
good chance our producer Nick's in there
Hanna I think I I think that'd be a
really funny book if you ever put that
out just to see all the things all the
unique pickup lines that somebody would
send um you know there would just be so
many so many funny angles people could
go especially the guys she gets I'm
southern bumpkins Hey so is there
noodling season like is there seasons to
it in some studies there is a legal
season but we were mostly in Alabama we
noodled in Alabama Tennessee Illinois
Kentucky North Carolina we've noted
several places but in Alabama there's
not a legal season it's just when the
water warms up enough for them to bathe
it and so right now their first start um
I got one fish this year and she tore me
up and what the eyelet is sexy yeah I'm
girls shooting that for drafted - hey
and so what tears you up their teeth or
their whiskers stupid question it was a
good question and now
is mainly we catch flat heads and blue
cat hairs have a bigger mouth but the
blue cats fight about ten times harder
well I'd love to go down there and try
that your flight is your blue mouth yeah
now what am I gonna say no so when you
reach under the water
do you just reach anywhere is it just
like fish and we're on us put the line
in wherever like you have like a little
worm in your hand like what do you do
well we found where their bed and
they've got we've got hundreds of
natural holes that we found over the
past eight years they bathe pretty much
anywhere where that sunlight can't get
to because sunlight will kill their eggs
so we under concrete is really good like
under boat ramps oh yeah hundreds of
natural holes under boat ramps under sea
walls that we have found and every lake
that we go to but we also put out boxes
we've always started doing that the past
few years because it's just it's more
fun you stick your arm in there and
usually you don't have to get that deep
in there and they're blowing your hand
up oh hell yeah dude it's like kind of
like a Christmas have like kind of a gay
men's club a little bit yeah they blow
you up
they can't Fischer
when they first go in is the male and
he's cleaning out the hole of the
nesting area for the female to come in
and lay her eggs while she lays her eggs
she leaves and the male stays in there
so what they're doing is they're
protecting their nesting area and their
eggs because briam other fish will come
in and eat their eggs so when you put
your hand in there they're attacking
well now do you have a hatred for tap
fishes and more of a sport thing when we
turn back if I go right back to their
eggs well that's cool amen hurting the
fish we've been doing it long enough
that we know how to hold them where does
it hurt them at all but we'll keep some
of the smaller ones to eat because we do
love fried egg and what's the biggest
one you've caught well I caught a
flathead last year and there was two
scales were used one of them said it was
61 pounds and the other one said saving
DC loot
we just split it happened said 67 but
she was here she was a fake she was
swallowing me almost up to my elbow oh
my that is sexy elbow dog it gets
naughty man fish or wild man so now are
you able to compete with this like I
mean yeah such a huge following so many
people are fascinated I think are you
are you able to take this in is there a
competitive world for this there's not
much of one just because I mean some
people love it people to try to either
love it or they hate it but there it is
it can be dangerous Wow so one face out
cult this year was a blue cat my biggest
blue cat it was 61 pounds it's the
hardest I've ever been bit and they can
break your arm
they spin just right they can break you
fell away Joe win a lot he's been doing
it for 50 years his daughter actually
broke her got her arm broke if you're 60
pound fish you ever reach in and get
surprised by like a snapping turtle
anything little sketchy and you'll be in
the water and you look up and a gator
head will pop up now what size are you
are in stature how tall are you Hannah
Wow and you just wrangling these town
and wrangling these kalfa is probably
pretty good fight every now and then
yeah I wonder if that's amazing that you
with your stature you know you got a
more of a petite stature to go in there
and get that I mean getting a fish
that's 60 pound that's half your body
weight
she's like the Paige van zan of catfish
yeah sometimes when I can't touch to
come up and get air everybody else can
oh yeah toss on that snorkel girl yeah
do you wear a snorkel never tried that
which really went like blue catechol the
other day I keep going back that cuz
it's the only fish I've caught this year
and she bout what my tail
I'm surprised more blind people don't
try this board really kind of well she's
done need to see it's all about few oh
yeah that's right it's all about feeling
huh well you don't even have to feel you
just stick your arm in there I used to
go in with my hand open mm-hmm feel
around but last year I got this finger
when I'm got a hold it and twist it and
they thought it broke my hand
he's like my whole poem turned blue and
everything and we went and found out it
was just really bad sprain which I broke
my hand a few times and that hurt worse
than when it was sprained but now I go
in with a fist you just go straight yeah
girl Wow and so uh this is the last
question that I have is um do you uh are
you gonna be noodling your entire life
you think like I want you to do this
does your mama noodle my mom does it
what does she think about it like I said
we just started about eight years ago
when our local game warden Brad Gavin's
took us right but my mom and dad are
divorced my mom wants to try so I'm
probably gonna try to take her some time
this year she's getting pretty excited
about it
are you surprised by the kind of the
notoriety and the the fame you've gotten
from noodling yes it was all an accident
really home I was always like the weird
girl in high school oh you know because
back then it wasn't cool behind always a
girl in Alabama it's not cool I feel
like the cool kid would show up in camo
it wasn't man it was for the guys but
not for the girls I got breakups because
I hunted too much oh yeah
but the reason all of this started is we
bought like a little piece of junk video
camera eight years ago in to earn no not
eight years ago this all started the
social media stuff started in 2016 we
brought a little video camera just to
test out recorded one video and I posted
on Instagram
catch you about a thirty pound catfish
my cousin's talking in the background it
sounds like a redneck reel
yes real bad my worse than I do right
now
it got Reshard several times
somebody reposted on Facebook got over
20 million views ever since then it all
started growing know that it was all on
accident I didn't send it to anybody it
just happened and do you think it's
because of the cat or do you think it's
because you're an attractive lady a
little bit everything
my cousin talking sounded like the
redneck background true and at that
point nobody had really seen much noodle
and other than like the hillbilly
handfishing TV shows yeah it wasn't
heard of much you know now I feel like
it's growing a lot a lot more people are
doing it but at that point I feel like
you know it was unheard of yeah I'm sure
did we we wouldn't know about it if we
didn't see you yep and I know me and see
if we would get into noodling we're
gonna come down and see if you take us
out could we do it if we came down do
you think we could fit emotionally
handle it why can't we take new people
all the time we've got several new
people coming this year that have no
idea my best friend can't swim and she's
not sure oh hell yeah I want to watch
that I'll watch I'll go down underwater
and get her and I'll get the fish with
you yeah and it's a great Hannah thanks
so much when we get near Alabama we'll
definitely come and experiences oh be
hilarious mom thank you so much and uh
best of luck at your friend's wedding I
hope you all hope you guys have a nice
time yeah we're good thank you
take care protect them elders buy in a
dude it's hard not to top an accent
al cabone girl Lily well damn girl
oh dude that chick what did you think of
that of that young lady Chappell I
thought it was insane that I saw people
tagging her and that's how I found and I
sent it Nick
I was like yo she's like the queen of
noodling but what you think just now
only talk to her oh she's a great person
very like you know tractive noodle her
yeah yeah yeah we're fist you I'd go at
her legs and yeah you know you throw
thick Tiffany down there yeah fish ain't
biting yeah baby biting that they trying
to deep throat her arm okay yeah some of
the fish definitely have more of a
homoerotic yeah does a Fisher just like
they throw a man down throw that old boy
hose that back down in the water oh
that's crazy that the animals in there
that's ready to bite you know and
protected I don't know and it should be
in your blood Vietnamese there's a lot
of fishing yeah a lot of fishing my dad
and my grandpa were fishermen in Vietnam
before they left
Wow so this is to be right up your alley
here it should be Bobby home base for
you give water just feels natural yeah
imagine cash mm-hmm if you were there
you imagine you could be you'd be a
sensation I feel like in this sport yeah
you know like yeah you could be there
yeah yeah you be the queen noodling yeah
if you want if you like think quickly if
you went into it you could definitely
you be yeah you take it over bring your
sponsorship because it's prop this is
probably big in Vietnam isn't it uh you
know this sounds like something every
Vietnamese fishermen probably does on
the weekend
do they have catfish in Vietnam yeah we
love catfish wow this is just check
check check all Bob her name's Kat she's
catfishing cat catfishing and he get
your toes out tap the boys go crazy
started yet only Santa CalFire noodley
yeah how fish would like it she's gonna
catch half our list
[Music]
the king
[Music]